this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
Phil and Rex and Vinnie Dimebag what is
that come on dude no Shin's only worn
that shirt for seven years I don't know
I don't pay attention to these things
guys happy Monday what is your shirt
happy yeah
there's a there's a hunting gear okay
great hunting gear the best hunting gear
can I give you something about it hold
on this can't help them sales because
you don't hunt well I've I've hunted if
that's like me having a Barbie shirt on
like go see Barbie everybody can I give
you something about Eberly stock which
is phenomenal not a lot of people you're
trying to they outfit who who do they
who does Everly stock out I have I have
it under good authority Kim Haynes a
group called Delta Force
uh I have a feeling they probably need
good gear their their stuff is really
good it's fine dude I'm the best yeah
cool so if you're only selling or you're
hunting or you gotta go find food you
got a camera man I can't emphasize
enough dude neither one of us all right
I'm really shocked neither are you when
I go hunting you know you put that
outfit we're talking about a person who
like takes trt bought a fast car yeah
it's like him yeah that's you with
clothes right yeah you mean like I want
to look like a hunter like you wear like
you know these shirts I may go hunting
at the end of September yeah me too with
a certain someone and I'm an and Eberly
stock is going to outfit me with with uh
I'm gonna I'm gonna reach out to Everly
stock and they're gonna give me stuff I
need for elk hunting dude at the end of
the day hey what matter you know what
I'm saying does for you it doesn't
that's a guy because you're gonna go
once again you might go one time yeah in
your in your 50s yeah you need you need
I need because you know I you know I
track hard you know how I track hard I'm
like let's go over here you guys they're
like Dude too many thorns I'm like shut
the [__] up
did they send you that shirt in the mail
they did
yeah they did yeah I don't really
appreciate you and then you feel
obligated to do this no I I actually
have never worn this shirt I just saw it
in my oh my God got a lot of I got a lot
of shirts in my drawer and I went um and
I put it on sometimes with my black
jeans I like the color I was doing this
this big meeting on Zoom you know
everything zoomed out doing this big
meeting and lacks my magic comes in you
know obviously Lex is you know his
military vet guys guy
he's a shirt it's a professional I mean
people in suits he's on their American
flag behind a half American flag half
Marines shirt says try and take my guns
AK-47 like I'm like come on dude hey
lash yeah you look like you're in the
capital right now these storm Nancy
Pelosi's [__] what office right could
you
know I was at the SHOT show and I went
into the Everly stock thing and here's
what I like about it they're very good
at like so bring them back and look at
the pictures because it makes you feel
like like when I'm such a sucker I'll go
in there I actually it is the best
quality you can buy they want the
company huh but who's their competitor
first light you know I've worn because
remember I do the the uh ranella stuff
so I wear a lot of different stuff but
like they use the guys who actually work
at the company as their models and like
yes you see that stuff like go back
right you see this stuff and you're like
yeah dude maybe you know I might need
that I might need uh a [__] you know
backpack yeah but they're not showing
more of the pictures you want to go to
the
yeah I'm just telling you that I get I
get I'm influenced by certain things
they have other pictures all right like
that like oh I gotta I gotta
that's how I want to make my coffee in
the morning oh look at that look at how
it protects you it is actually a really
good [__] though military stuff
military yeah there that's what I'd be
doing I'm not sure what he's doing there
but I'll do that in the Stream he's
filling up his canteen yeah glass and
yeah
but it is it is real [__] look at that a
bow what do you think of archery
the way I think this conversation in the
podcast
let's cover other companies
yeah I don't know dude shot on my magic
oh how was uh Springfield I loved it
it's good market right
Chris and Chris and Addie who run that
club they're great they took me to um
they took me to uh to do the caves you
got caves I didn't I was gonna go the
case I got there you'd appreciate this
and you go under the caves now they got
more caves in Missouri apparently than
anywhere else I didn't know there's a
long history of haunted history of those
caves well when you talk about caves
you're talking about like stalactites
you know the kind of caves where the you
know the water drip yeah like fossilizes
yeah so it's a really it's a real cave
that goes way deep right because the
history of the cavestone there's a
picture so you get this so we get there
and there's like a haunted town it was a
haunted history there where was it at
Missouri Missouri uh Springfield but so
so I go there and and I'm like you know
we're gonna go through the caves now
when I think of caves I think all right
I'll go walk through the caves no no sir
you go there and you wait in line get a
ticket and you're gonna hold there's
that many people and you're getting a
trolley oh no no oh no with a bunch of
uh real slow and it's an hour oh no no
it's an hour sir I can't walk myself you
sure can't because dangers it isn't but
they just have it locked up where you
can make money off the cave he kept
telling me to go to the caves but it's
like 30 minutes away yeah now did you go
to Bass Pro Shop now I did how
impressive let's talk about you could
have got your hunting gear there dude
did you go through there did you go
through the aquarium I sure did it
destroys Long Beach Aquarium it's
fantastic it's crazy now those there you
go and that's the trolley and I took a
look at the pictures and I went I seen
the cave now but I'm not doing that I'm
not doing it unless I can get on like
get my hands on those things and get
lost now if my energy gets my energy
shoots up a little bit it's because of
my
it's because of my magic mind if you
took that and walk through those caves
you could have broke some of those
things off yeah that's true but I'm I'm
pretty sure it's haunted there's some
weird haunted haunted stuff in Missouri
but Springfield has hot some haunted
[__] dude well well so um then I went to
the bass pro shop now how impressive is
it now yeah the the Johnny Morris I
guess who's the guy who started it out
of his like out of the trunk of his car
in a garage of course now built this the
like one of the most successful American
businesses period and he's a Avid hunter
fisher himself he's close with the Bush
family do you see Bush's boat I didn't
oh if you go through there but it's his
fishing boat he gave it to him when he
was elected president sick yeah well he
he uh apparently they were like you know
Johnny if you put you can't have octopus
and sharks and you can't have a black
bear and he goes well how much is it and
they go it would be this much and he
goes he'd go look at his watch and he
goes I just made it let's go he did it
all and he built it in Springfield
Missouri Oh bro it takes you about two
hours archery Museum you got a Firearms
Museum you've got black rifles
everywhere there Black Rifle coffee they
have their own my buddy who's the CEO
was the one who's like you know because
they have a thing there he's good friend
if you have the brick and mortar like
giant shop a Black Rifle there but who
thought did you go to the restaurant
upstairs the old school restaurant I did
it's good you can't even see I didn't
eat that though I just went and looked
at it I feel like you can't even you
can't even like I how is it you can go
to Missouri and I saw every everything
that lives in the sea pretty much
yeah you don't have an aquarium yeah oh
the guy the guy who who works at uh you
know did you see that huge redhead just
giant Viking redhead no okay he was he
was working the door and he was there at
uh at the blue room but he works at the
aquarium every day that's his day job so
he Dives in there he's like Mr and he
has a chunk missing out of his ear right
here no this little fish it's this
little shitty it's called a Darby or
something it's like this aggressive fish
I thought of you came up and bit that
[__] here just went now he's
Gotta Wear hoodie and cover his ears
because these things are like now that
looks delicious because he might be a
Darby he's Deuce bigalowing it he's
jumping in cleaning the tanks oh yeah
you're cleaning the tank it's a beast oh
yeah
yeah the only the only aquarium I've
seen better than there is Atlantis
Atlanta's aquarium really so legit yeah
like Coca-Cola they had this giant
specific octopus that was just all over
it was incredible and you're there for
two hours yeah they're crocodiles
alligators I was feeling dizzy because I
had an ear thing going on I don't know
what's going on so I ran through
you could get through pretty fast I ran
through and it took me 45 minutes that's
how big it is oh damn yeah me and Jay
took our sweet time sweet time but I
love this I'll teach Jay about the fish
now now those aquariums some of those
bigger aquariums cost see daddy likes to
I always ask you in the back because I
like to look at the filtration systems
because I'm a nerd you do I love the
it's insane these filtrations we have
this whole room for the the filtration
is millions of dollars in itself and
it's a real science the engineers have
to build the filtration system all the
waste the food circulating the water the
the bacteria right because remember they
get an important they got to import salt
water in there
all those aquariums oh so they can't
they can't they usually have ocean water
you can but it doesn't have like it'll
take forever for it to cycle so the fish
is healthy in there so you get so you
actually yeah look at that I took that
they had to transfer a 400 pound grouper
from downstairs to an upstairs tank and
it took them three hours nightmare I've
seen that to sedate it yeah oh damn you
spray a sedation you spray something in
space and go to sleep
so then you had a 400 pounds Bill
Cosby's like they held up
you want to go swimming it's easier to
go swimming
um oh I did I I thought I asked chin I
thought I sent to the group did it did
maybe you saw George why my uh we caught
another lizard a bigger lizard oh I saw
that uh bro I'm telling people thought I
was lying dude bro Savage bro you you
have if you're a lizard in that if
you're a lizard and they you get dropped
in a bearded dragons you have less time
than you would if you jumped into a tank
with a saltwater crocodile dude no
chance what'd I tell you no they go what
what they go come over here and they
just kill it but I think because they're
so kid-friendly people don't believe me
and I told my dad I'm like damn I'm
telling because Tiger's like Dad I want
another lizard I'm not buying another
[__] pair of dragon so like if you
catch a big enough one that they won't
eat we'll do it I don't know if we
should play a chin might get his flag
we'll just play for you guys then I saw
it yeah we saw it you guys didn't see it
watch how fast ready
look at it so the little ones like it
already knows little one's like what's
up one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand four one thousand five one
thousand Here Comes Big Daddy
sit on my tank seven seconds
dude that didn't even have a chance deep
throats it too just stuck its tongue out
Whoomp I'll take you and the other guy
didn't get a bite what that mouth do
baby
so much do you just deep throat that
whole thing man I was feeding mines
crickets and put your balls
yep which balls what did he say he's put
your balls in my mouth
I told my lizard said that other lizard
said well there you go put your dick in
a bottle you dress and drag
my Lord but in Springfield it's a little
I I'm pissing to stay in the hotel and
they get a discount
because I I am spending on an Airbnb
that wasn't that good an old farmhouse
rickety that's what makes it the best
thing is it's right near the club it's
like I stayed on Commercial Street which
by the way was founded by wiccans you
know there are more wiccans you know
what wiccans are they're like witches
who are into white magic or something
yeah so those women who like like in
there and opened no that would be
Wickers no it's wicked no Wickers you
know what a warlock is uh-huh a Wiccan I
want to be witch usually someone who
understands witchcraft but doesn't
practice it well they're basically the
Bro signs culture yeah yeah yeah they
don't know their [__] that's what they
pretend they do and they dress like them
yeah
you're a wicker so
no it's wicking we're gonna get flagged
the point wicker the point is
that
um
they have a bunch of stores there I
guess which is like did you go into new
no I didn't I don't want to buy crystals
I don't give a [__] about crystals or
wind chimes that's a weird one or
whatever it is you have I like that
stuff like your turquoise Talisman oh
dude you know the right up here you know
the Jacks of night where it's at the
Gillette Ranch the the pumpkin Jack's at
night you definitely take your son there
but it's during Halloween the the King's
Ranch is that giant Ranch they do the
Jacks of night and they have the dopest
like pumpkin patch and this whole
Halloween thing I go there every year
every year you know one of my favorite
shows is Ghost Adventures with my boy
Zach Baggins right this thing's by far
the best thing I think in North America
it comes to Halloween there's nothing
better really so I go every year I and I
ride my bike there probably three times
a week around there whatever
you know my favorite show is Ghost
Adventures right Zach Baggins well on
there not a big deal season seven so
they're on scene 28 no big deal so me
and Zach whatever shoot this [__] all
the time and me my my wife's favorite
show we click on it says Calabasas
Calabasas uh Gillette Ranch I was like
Gillette Ranch I like that's where
that's where nights of Jack is at click
on it we watch it dude that place is
dark history really because Gillette who
you know started razors the [__]
Gillette razors bought that place but
when he bought it it was on Indian land
so I killed all these Indians bought
that whole compound then he had to sell
for whatever reason the city made him
sell it and then a Colt came in there it
was like killing people not so it's such
a dark history well Springfield which I
didn't know was kind of like the the
line where it was like slavery is kind
of legal like living the lid like if you
wanna if you want slaves you can they
were kind of like I think that Missouri
was kind of like iffy and uh they had a
uh they I I was told and I saw it they
and looked this up they had a tower
where they used to hang slaves and it's
still standing like the Town Square
they're still standing and it was just
is that where I get my coffee and yeah
you're like damn this is this is
this is where it goes three men lynched
uh uh 1906 lynching is that where Jason
Aldean did his country music video
Springfield yeah
um anyway it was that's probably the
Public Square that Public Square is like
the Heart of the City
that place is dope but that's what's
great about stand-ups when like you know
what would you ever go to Springfield no
and now I will of course I had a great
time when I when I got off the road from
doing I told him I'm like next time we
got we gotta bring the kids they could
just hang out all day at Bass Pro it's
all day all day all day alligators
albino alligators flamingos flamengos
they had everything there it's great for
kids oh so back to that Gillette Ranch
so I text Zachary oh dude just got done
with your new episode that Gillette
Rancho I live like five minutes from
there I'm there all time my kids he goes
oof and I go yeah I had no clue I said
that's that's dope you know that hunt
stuff is dope and then he goes yeah man
uh you down to come back on I said I do
this my favorite show I love that stuff
and I go what which one are you doing
next because the one we're doing next
not is not scary enough for you he's
like let's wait till we have like the
most scary like most history one and
then I'm gonna call you I was like all
right say less yeah I love that [__]
yeah that's been going on for a long
time what's it called excuse me sir
Ghost Adventures ready for this 28
season he's got all the money
bro he bought he bought uh James Dean's
old Porsche I mean Jay were trying to
look up how much it went for just in his
Haunted Mansion like some of the
artifacts in there aren't you talking
millions of dollars just on like a few
things damn yeah all the money you got
all the money oh my you got a show that
goes that way 28 seasons can we come up
with a show that everybody would watch
can we come up with something can we
just do that I mean it goes I don't know
let's just come you're on record saying
don't believe it dude so now it's on
yeah but that's even better you believe
in ghosts I don't and we can go and I
love that stuff we can go and look for
ghosts I I would like like uh if he lets
me pick I'd like to do something like
whether it's the Night Stalker stuff
around La or if you even uh spawn Ranch
we go there with the mans and stuff I
got my black belt on that if he gets me
off in some weird [__] I don't know it
gets a little dicey you know well what
do you start making stuff with can we
come up with a show dude I want to make
all the money I want to buy a Jeep
20 28 seasons
and not on like [__] like whatever
you don't realize how much money that is
when you keep bringing a gun you just
signed for more seasons I mean it's
gonna oh and he's on HBO now Bubba he's
on HBO Max really and Discovery those
are the number one show
so they license out to all those
different 28 Seasons dude if you want
the amount of money that dude makes and
they just replay them all the time and
then so Zach Baggins crushing TV the
only other guy I know is crushing like
Kim bring up Zach and I know the details
Zach's you'd love Zach Zach's such a
good dude he's a boy's in shape to hunt
ghosts but uh Rob Dyrdek
too
well I was I was thinking about his
success it's also you know how many
Ghost Hunters there are in the world
dude yeah great yeah dying people and
one of the reasons he's tall too right
yeah he's not small uh he might be my
size Jesus yeah and he's a billionaire a
millionaire like that he's a stud yeah
he's one of those guys probably really
smart and disciplined like you can see
wait he was dating Holly Madison looks
like it holy [__] this guy's crushing it
but it looks like the dude ghost hunting
for dummies I'll buy that for you
um Zach writes it ghost hunting for
morons he's got a great name Zach
Baggins the whole thing just works it
just works but but then I was thinking
about like he's like whenever someone's
the face of something even at its Niche
even though ghost is massive but
whatever it is if there's a face of that
you're making so much money because like
if you go he's in there he's in the cars
huh I'm done he's one of us he's the
best but if there's if there's like
whatever it is like you think how many
ghost hunting like there's other ghosts
there's ghosts oh there's a ghost hunter
show but you watch it like oh there's
just not that it's just not as done as
well they don't talk the camera as well
don't have the like Charisma well he did
our podcast he was like years ago my my
wife my girl got in a full-scale tug of
war with a ghost with her purse yeah
you gotta love them but when you think
about it on YouTube like even Rogan had
these two younger Ghost Hunters on this
show that ghost of Adventures like Ghost
Hunter like uh Niche audience not even
it's massive but they're they're so
popular but Zach's the face of it yeah
my buddy uh Chad is a ghost hunter
and uh I went on does Chad make money
doing it I think he makes he's got
different documentaries but it's hard
it's hard business to make money the
hardest
by the way let's just take a minute you
might hold on I'm gonna make a call
right now Zach Baggins might be the
biggest Genius of all time he made
millions and millions of dollars as a
ghost hunter now if I said to you I got
I know what I'm gonna do dad with my
life what I'm Gonna Be a Ghost Hunter
I'd be like oh no oh my God my son's a
disaster and he's like Chad
Chad Kalik uh Chad's a big time Ghost
Hunter Chad hunting sandwiches right
Chad's lost a lot of weight actually
but uh yeah he's a paranormal I would
love to even have I I find it
fascinating but this is what's different
about Zach too
and I know you're skeptical of it but
they they have the they have these
instruments now on the new seasons that
gauge Just Energy and just hear me out
I'm listening hey I listen to your
hunting stuff right
they have a device that gauges energy
and they don't control it yeah and it
does the energy
but they also have but it shows figures
like if there's another thing in the
room it does I know figures huh I'm
telling you what energy is it is it uh
is it you can engage energy you can
engage energy yeah but what energy like
what do you mean when Zack's on he'll be
able to fill you yeah magnetic field
yeah yeah there's energy that's around
us all the time well that'd be a soul
right which is also known as a ghost or
it could just be the electromagnetic
field which makes these mics work and
that things no no because they'll show
like the the of their mic and all that
I'm telling you dude no I'm just saying
you haven't watched one you watch one
you're like all right I'm saying do you
know how but you know how the
electromagnetic field like do you know
how we harnessed electricity which is in
the air it's pretty fascinating The
History of Science where you take up
that's all open Timer you take adhesive
metal and let's put it in yeah
I think Barstool posted this yeah look
at that oh you can't buy them yeah 300 I
need one from my house because I watch
so much ghost [__] now my girl thinks
we're a house is haunted this is
incredible out of stock
dude when they talk to the spirit
bro EVP risk recorder
that's a big thing what's that laser
grid system yeah amazing that's a that's
359 look at that Teddy Bear if a ghost
touches it it lights up
where's that real ghost it's a bear
I don't know this was available I will
buy half of that [__]
this is incredible
it's interesting right well Chad came to
my old house because my you're running
Calabasas yeah no no the one in Santa
Monica my ex the new one my ex no the
one in Santa Monica my the my ex swore
that she would hear footsteps and saw
German Shepherds because
I hear that that one the first one I
went to I don't you've been to my my old
house my old my house in Santa Monica
the one that you're actually lives in
yes oh we'll just say yeah so so that
house
I don't know if you know the story
behind that I know the land the the
people died well the guy so the guy who
used to own the house that that they
built over on top of but when they build
a house on top of they keep the
foundation and stuff that guy hung both
his German Shepherds
um or drown them both they must have
been bad dogs killed himself they must
have been bad dogs well yeah he didn't
want them to suffer oh God nobody can
take care of you the way I can and then
he killed himself oh he's crazy yes and
the neighbor found him he's like ah but
by the way they built this thing so now
my my my my ex swears she saw German
Shepherds she heard them there's some
dark energy there and then and then
Stevie blue eyes stayed at our place and
said you got ghosts upstairs yeah you
got ghosts and I'm like Stevie come on
but Stevie's not like that no he's like
manner you got whatever's going on you
guys so Chad comes in with this yeah big
dog come over I had big dog come over
and he was like well it's called ghost
daddy ghost daddy ghost daddy comes up
if you're here give us a sign and I'll
tell you this we had lights in the back
outside and the lights lit up and my ex
was like
and you think it's all [__]
yes I do
yes I do yes the government's looking
out for our interests and covid was real
God dog I want to hit you man I can take
the politics stuff yeah you start hating
on ghosts dude I'm [__] you up right do
it you be ghosts do it you're a big gay
ghost see what happens because you know
what I am when it comes to fighting
you're a gay guy start hidden I'm a
ghost I'm behind you you don't know what
the [__] happened that would be great
[__] name ghost if you had good
defense ghost you're catching air they
call me the ghost when it comes to
boxing what a great name Doug they call
it as a boxer the ghost there has to be
some of that nickname I always that's
what I call myself when I say next to
people no no no no I go I'm the ghost
because there's ghosting where you just
stop talking to someone
you catch an error every time you hit me
honestly no boys but you don't believe
in any like you like on any of the
spirit stuff like the bad energy you
just think when we die it's all over
like there's no bad energy like some
souls are caught here I believe in God
and I believe in the eyes well if you
believe in god there you go I believe in
I believe in uh I give you a colonel no
I believe in you took it things like
this watch this like I think my my I I
like a spiritual outlook on on the
universe what's that mean I think
anything that happens to you anything
that happens to you good or bad it's
good because it's what the universe
instead of looking at what you can get
from the universe ask what the universe
is trying to get out of you Jen look
this up if it's a Hallmark card I was
trying to universe trying to get you to
grow so if bad things happen to you it's
just a test become a better person yeah
right I agree it depends your way of
looking at it I don't believe in
coincidence yeah and I I just don't and
I also like what Jordan Peterson said he
said 35 years of psychoanalysis I've
never seen anyone get ever get away with
anything even once I like that because I
I think Jack the Ripper says hold mine
yeah I think there are there are certain
things that dovetail with the universe's
laws if you if you walk a righteous path
it's going to work out for you even if
it doesn't in a way right so I have
those thoughts I mean there's a longer
conversation but in terms of ghosts so
like you like you could move into Sharon
Tate's house off CeeLo drive and be fine
of course yeah you'll have the 30
million dollar house now they took it
down and it's up it's for sale now for
30 mil yeah I would 100 that house is
dope I couldn't doing that up I couldn't
do it I couldn't do it why you'd be
afraid
yeah I believe in some of that stuff so
it'd always be on my mind couldn't relax
you believe in what like that they that
Spirits like I think I think there's
good and bad and so the bad spirits
would do what
there it is that's for sale
oh I'm moving there and do you
understand filthy you know what I could
probably live there I'll figure it out
even with the ghost but here's the other
thing with the ghost now though
whether you believe it or not you know
when some people get possessed that
scares me but outside that like even
with Zach's investigations and they'll
have other Ghost Hunters on there like
yeah I was hearing the ghost pick me up
and threw me I'm like all right that's
not terrible but if they if like if the
ghosts are like stab me they like knock
[__] down okay I live with that
they knock stuff down they turn on a
light or they experience the ghosts like
they never do anything too bad they
don't do anything they go now I will say
this my aunt was staying at a hotel in
Chatham New York I think my mom was
there and she said he said how was your
night and she said I could not sleep all
night I had this terrible dream there
was a woman who was grabbing me by the
hair and yanking me around and pulling
my hair and the woman goes oh she got
white and she goes oh my God what
and the guy the guy who was there said
she's back she's back she goes what do
you mean she goes she's been in people's
dreams and she's been she was gone for a
while and now she's back she's killing
our she's doing this to our guests
that's weird that's a little scary yeah
because but did you grow up like does
your mom or dad believe it did anyone
believe like my grandma like the English
heavily Indigo [__] my mom swears by it
my grandma my dad will never my dad said
oh you're dead straight I wouldn't even
ask him but my mom my mom is maybe a
she's more afraid of real people She's
Not Afraid of like oh me too she you
know it's more real people ghosts like
like the kind of ghosts in The Conjuring
and stuff that's not good well that's
when they possess people like that now
are you coming to my house to mess with
my kids I don't care who you are I don't
care I don't care who you are you come
in and mess with my kids you you
interfere with their sleep you start
haunting them you better pack a lunch
you [__] demon yeah because I'm gonna
be real quick
hey you know what you're gonna do what
you're gonna call Daddy a ghost right
yeah hey you're gonna post mates where
he gets there right he needs a meal
before he starts I'm bringing we're
gonna call my boy Zach Baggins yeah but
the way you're talking that thing coming
yeah we need the help anyone I don't
need anyone I'm gonna go where they are
I'm gonna go where is it you can't see
him you can't see it oh it's okay I'm
gonna sit up all night I'll keep the
I'll keep everything dark and I want you
to bring your worst demons that's what
they want bring your worst demons yes no
this this is good know this I'm digging
my heels this is good I'm into the into
the wood the wood of mine this is good
and I'm coming for you you're so good
I'm Coming For You [__] see this could
be a show and if you're a nun with a
mouth like in the country like that
terrified I will dive into her I will
run so far yes and I'll dive into her I
will run something
dive like this like this like dive into
I want to get into her and then you're
possessed dude and I'm gonna possess her
I'm the possessor like they're right
there that scares the [__] out of me
actually that thing was scary oh no when
it's just a face when not doing that
that's very scary that thing's
terrifying actually I'd have a problem
if I saw that I'd be really afraid of B
you don't believe in like like dude I
just got I just got you that shit's
scary Jesus the movie the night right
that's scary but oh I love it how about
that poor actress I have to be honest go
up to the real actors to be honest
that's really scary which one is it this
one no no go all the way up
ain't that a [__] whoa she's pretty but
you would be like hey do I know oh my
God you're that you you couldn't date
her oh my God that's scary she's hot too
she's got a strong face she's got a very
face with a great deal wrong nose that's
a strong nose that's I call that makeup
but but
um mako shark dude um that's who plays
this yeah wow but she is you're very
like her facial expressions are very
strong look at that but you don't
believe in like like when it like the
the Kennedy families cursed
like the Cur like the curses and stuff
like they don't believe in any of that I
don't
I just don't
you know what you are what
not fun I know
I don't believe in Superstition that way
you don't believe the government's ever
screwed us over you don't believe in
ghosts or tell the future
I think that people can read human
beings and their behavior and make very
good guesses
you don't believe it like you don't
think anybody on the planet has like
this like somewhat of a medium where
they can see or talk to spirits nothing
not at all even a little bit yeah I feel
you that one's tough that one's tough
I'm Amazed by the people that do it and
make money doing like good for you man
oh yeah they're con man they're common
Zach Bagans is different Zach Bagans is
a great interview he believes it he's
got he's a great Entertainer he's got a
great show yeah and he and more power to
him but people like psychics that take
money from people they're con men now
people who are willing to get conned and
they're just providing a service that's
it they're providing a service
it's all good you guys believe in ghosts
chin yeah I used to watch ghost
adventure religiously you believe in God
I've seen I've seen every episode
Asians get down with ghosts dude that
guy John Edward is was they did a show
on him that guy is in my opinion which
one is he huge which one huge frog this
guy here in the middle not a good guy
from what I can tell that guy they they
did a whole thing on him he he was uh he
they have they have microphones
on the audience when they're waiting in
the waiting room and they find out what
they're saying I mean come on well yeah
he's a crook but the the the Jersey
Shore lady you know she does like Arenas
now
yeah if you want to make money that way
good for you it's you're basically an
Entertainer this guy John Edward is
basically an Entertainer he's an actor
and he's making a lot of money I don't
he's fine he's he's probably a guy who's
like dude I'll tell you what John
Edwards probably is he probably wanted
to be an actor he came up with a great
idea and he's like I can make money
doing this I can make money I can have a
crazy show and and and charge people but
isn't it kind of dope it's amazing isn't
it kind of dope if they can get someone
like closure like I'm talking to your
your sister who died on popular oh she
says she's fine yes and those people
move on that's kind of dope 20 mil he
got a little bit exposed I guess
from what I understand 20 mil though
expose me yeah right I suppose me too
um
Sylvia Brown apparently hey man you lied
on some of these things he's like yeah
my feeling with it it's complicated with
guys like John Edward because what they
do is they go dude I bet you in private
they'd be like hey dude there are people
willing to pay me a lot of money to hear
what they want to hear and I tell them
what they want to hear but it'd be like
being mad at David Blaine yeah hey dude
is that real right like magic he's like
don't be a dumbass right you're right
people pay to see it no it's not real
but you are going to a minute but I mean
you right but you're going to that it's
to me it's the same thing I agree it's
like he's a psychic okay and John
Edwards has a psychic daughter or
whatever probably it becomes a family
business
yeah hey [__] you got the same gift
it's hard to make money if you can make
that much money you know
I don't know she's she's oh Dad I can
see it too like yeah see she her his
kids an actress I'm sure John Edwards
probably look up John Edwards I
guarantee he probably tried to be an
actor I will guarantee it I don't know
who he is
he he had that crossing over show for a
long time oh no I'm sorry oh not the not
the politician
see yeah American television person I
author and self proclaimed psychic
mediocre
uh Ryan's first book on the subject
and he's just very good at this he's on
he's on a Sci-Fi channel
um hold on Irish American police officer
Italian American working by the Irish
Italian baby
uh Roman Catholic although Edward let us
stop practicing that face he's quoted
saying that he never stopped feeling
connected to God still feels closely
connected to his Catholic Roots
um according to Edwards 15 he was a huge
doubter of course
you have to you always have to be I
became a ballroom dancing instructor
there you go Twinkle Toes there you go
he was at phlebotomist so he takes blood
dance studio I love it he was a ballroom
dancing instructor perfect he's one of
the Godfathers apparently of it love it
I love it let's take a little break
Brandon all right because it's about
unique health benefits and it's about
being able to eat something that's
delicious he's talking about nuts
buttery I'm talking about nuts you love
nuts in your mouth I'm talking about
macadamias lowering net carbs the most
popular nuts they're 33 less than
almonds fifty percent less than cashews
they have arguably the best fat profile
of any nut like avocado on steroids okay
they have more money on that saturated
fat
um they've got uh they've got Omega
seven fatty acids which can support
natural collagen production glucose
metabolism and reduce inflammation and
they're really good for satiety so if
you're trying to lose weight you eat a
couple of macadamia nuts they make you
feel full they're also ridiculously
delicious which is why they're the most
expensive and rarest of nut but House of
macadamia is working vertically with 90
plus farmers in South Africa in these
communities when they're struggling
economy so you say macadamia nuts just
aren't for the rich anymore dude no dude
and you're you're getting farmer can
they dip them in some a little bit of
chocolate for Me Maybe white chocolate
like I got regular regular chocolate
raspberry vanilla macadamia nut bars
which are delicious how about the creamy
Nut Butter fresh from the Harvest don't
you start on their extra virgin
Macadamia Oil oh my god dude it's Gotta
Give dude buttery flavor it's delicious
high smoke point great they're doing a
special discount right now for the fine
kid Army for limit time they're giving
you guys a free box of the 45 Macadamia
snack bars they're delicious one of each
flavor you get the variety pack then
choose then order your own when you
visit
houseomeacademias.com tfak you get 20
off your entire order with the code tfak
House of macadamias they're nutty
they're nuts I'll tell you what we know
what real for sure is the fights these
weekends you old [__]
oh can we talk about those fights yeah
which one you want to see
um well let me start with this question
for EB
I already know where Chin's at on this
yeah what's going to sell more
pay-per-views Errol Spence Crawford or
Nate Diaz Jake Paul I'm going to tell
you that Errol Spence Crawford should
sell more that's a nice review it should
because you're talking about two amazing
Craftsman I think
39-0 the other is 30 you know
and welterweights one is very strong and
hits very hard and Aerosmith's probably
going to go up a weight class after this
but Crawford is smaller in stature and
doesn't have as much trouble making the
weight they say Bud Crawford can do
fight the same way from both sides the
best the best as far as traditional
softball you've ever seen yes yeah and
is a genius because he can figure out
what you're doing he downloads your
information if you look at Errol Spence
though from what I un what I can see
he's such an uh uh uh his is a
minimalist style it's just ones twos
hooks it's like real simple yeah
upgraded the basics and I talked to
um our boy um who fought him who got
worked up by oh the South African film
uh Chris Van heerden yeah and I said
what was it about him he said I've never
found anybody who had the ability to
measure distance how well he can stay
just at the edge of the pocket he can
read and it's really hard because when
you throw you're you're just exposed so
so who you got man so I got I got I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go with uh Bud
Crawford what yeah because even before
we got
to win and I think Bud Crawford is so
smart that he will figure something out
it's going to be a crazy right now hold
on real quick here he gets caught you
make a mistake and Sarah Spence
do you Crawford I think it goes to a
decision is it a boring fight I don't
even know it's supposed to be like
boxing it's gonna be a great fight and
they both know it's like a legacy fight
the only reason why I side with Bud
Crawford he's been way more active he's
been way more active I think uh Spence
has only fought twice since 2019 and
he's had two car accidents he's had uh
surgery on his eye so he's not as active
that that stuff and when you're talking
about the tip of the spear guys like
this I give it to I give the answer very
good point
very good point
uh when was the last time you fought
what was that April 2022 okay that
Spence that's the tune-up thing
and then this is Crawford
December 2022. okay
go back for me chin
so far Sean Porter no joke
I saw that fight
so since so December so 2020 they took
two years off with that stuff so so he's
had one fight one fight in basically
three years and then look at Crawford
Crawford's been a lot more active and
fought you know Crawford
Kell Brook Sean Porter ton though either
but it's still more active so my Point's
not that great
yeah it's more active but
I'm just I'm worried about the the car
racks that's gonna do something to your
psyche there the car wrecks and then
also the surgery on the eye the retina
surgery
you know who else had retina surgery and
came back on one
Sugar Ray Leonard
so
a great great Fighters don't really it's
it's
just part of the game
um so I'm going with Bud Crawford
using a 488 spider a white uh 48 spider
convertible
he when he hit the car the pole where
the [__] he hit he didn't have a
seatbelt on if he would have stayed in
the car he would have crashed him would
have died he flew out I didn't enrolled
I didn't survived they say if you would
have seatbelt one of the rare times pays
off not having your seatbelt what the
[__] he flew out the top whoa and the
injuries weren't too bad like oh I know
now you could see that into a rude
awakening and he's training harder than
ever and it gets him in the right frame
of mind but yeah well God you know gave
God is this the actual side that's it
yeah you see him fall out
somewhere around dude they said if he
would have stayed on the car because the
car's flipping are you kidding me
I don't see him
yeah I can't see him I thought we saw it
last time on a road bro am I crazy oh my
God oh my God that poor guy oh my God
that's crazy how much that car
how many times it's flipping over
how fast was he going all the speed yeah
all the miles an hour oh come on
yeah
um
so that's my call on that
yeah I'm gonna take but but the the it
came off I think the lines are at uh
minus they're both minus 115 there's a
pickum now Bud's a slight barely it's
like minus what's the odds now chin
minus 135 minus 110. because he's a
southpaw no he can do both though yeah
it just depresses up
it's I'm so excited about this fight and
I'm going to be on stage at the Ontario
Improv this weekend everybody come see
me uh Friday Saturday Ontario Improv
plus 120 minus 150 in box and that's
like basically pick him and they did
start off as a pickup
I don't understand though because I'm
sitting down I'm interviewing uh Luke
Thomas I think he's working the fight
for Showtime so I'm gonna have him break
it down that [__] those boxes
yeah
so you got this B and then you also got
USD 291 yeah I'll tell you I'll go there
poor a just engage you you know I'm
going with Poirier
me too gotta go with Poirier
um and then but if you remember the
fight in 2018 it wasn't going great for
poorie man until that fourth round like
he was losing around that fourth round
then I poke and then he won from the leg
cakes but
and people go well since that loss just
engaging Trevor Whitman you know I love
trevoring on forever he's my coach but
like they they recalibrated his style
he's not as Reckless I'm like I don't
know and they're both like whether six
out of the last eight they've won six or
last eight but it's also like
the love of competition gaichi's fought
compared to Dustin party since then I'd
give the edge to poor age I don't know
if it's a if it's
gaichi fighting smarter he's just
fighting easier fights I said yeah
you're going to see more damage more
damage more damage with these two they
hit hard as [__] they stand there
they're really good and somebody's gonna
it's gonna be a my prediction is going
to be ugly and somebody I don't think so
beaten down I don't think so no I think
maybe I think Paulie submits them really
that makes sense because puree is legit
Jiu Jitsu filthy and our boy anybody who
takes poray down like unless you're
khabib but you know what takes party
down like his guard's nasty he's a legit
black belt I know and so the rumor is
that Justin gaichi isn't that something
about you K2 believes in Jutsu like you
believe in ghosts really yes
that's that's an issue so so that's the
smart money the smart money if you're
Dustin Poirier that you're saying is to
take him down get them into that cockpit
then shoot on them because remember
Justin Gates's hips are no punk
All-American and North America North
Northern Colorado like his wrestling's
filthy now he did use more wrestling in
his last fight against
popped up like a [__] Savage but
Porey he gets you down he's good down
there in transitions
he'll catch you but I do think gaichi's
you know if they look back at the fight
in 2019 easy to implement more leg kits
make him count try and take out his legs
but she's going to do that yeah that's
what he did in the first fight and the
leg kicks were a huge difference and
that's why uh Porey was down on the
cards I think two of the light kicks but
then also with leg kicks remember the
counter light Kick's not getting the
fight's gonna [__] the guy up the
counter the leg Kick's gonna stop the
fight that's what stopped the 2018 fight
so I think it's just a matter of time if
Corey catches him with the count of the
leg strikes but I do think and I think
he can stop him from kicking so much if
he implements his wrestling
if he starts leg kicking him and he just
goes into a dive dive double just
blasting the double man his hips are
ridiculous but every time he throws that
you just [__] dive into his hips he's
just said than done his hips are so good
yeah and that's all in training that's
all anybody tries to do to him
so we'll see Against the Cage I see him
having more success you can get you down
but in the open so do you think is
stronger or who do you think's stronger
in the clinch
I'll uh man gaichi's [__] tough
keichi has a lot of advantages
more explosive
[Music]
crazy get you better wrestle yeah not
even close yeah All-American yeah yeah
but at this stage these guys have been
doing it for so long so much American
but he has the capabilities and he has
more Tools in his in his shed to pull it
off who's more likely puts who on the
ground in a clinch
that's what I'm saying
yeah that's a good question I I'd lean
towards gaichi probably there but it
doesn't so good with his MMA wrestling
to your point he's got so many great
guys to train with at American Top
camera think about yeah the thing about
that top team gym which I've been to
several times is they have so many great
Russians like Olympians there who are
wrestlers so they're always training
with those guys so you're seeing every
look somebody throws at you I mean
yeah pretty good at wrestling yep
yeah it's a great fight though great
fight
the whole cards but the whole main card
is pretty tasty go that main card chin
the whole main card's pretty tasty buddy
yon and Alex Pierre you know what's
gonna happen there what do you think
well I know what's gonna happen well Jan
is going to wrestle Alex Pierre no and
by the way Jan is a lot bigger than a
guy named Izzy and if you think Alex
Pierre is going to stop Jan blockowitz
from putting him on his back that's
what's gonna happen it's going to be I'm
going to put you don't think Alex can
catch them though with that power at
light heavyweight he's so big sure he
can try to catch him but no I don't you
don't think he's gonna win I don't think
he can catch him I think he can he can
exchange I think those odds are the
closest ones on the entire card
I don't think I think Alex Pierre is
going to be
I want Alex to win I'm rooting for Alex
sure the division would be so fun if he
wins he's gonna have his hands full well
the UFC gave this fight to him it's like
man this guy's Superstar written all
over him after the Izzy stuff and then
remember he's grappling non-stop with
Glover yep he's grappling with clover
that's fine
he's such a fun character now and
there's so many fun matchups I'd like to
have you wait a few wins I think he's
awesome Johnny Walker versus him very
amazing but I just think he's got he's
got to deal with that that Russian guy
if he hits by this one though he's going
Sizzler because then they're like all
right we're not giving you money mad all
this morning I think you're going to see
the same thing that happened to Izzy as
happens too remember it took you on two
rounds to get Izzy down
yeah and Izzy is a better wrestler than
Alex yeah Alex is new to wrestling and
it's just a different thing now I don't
know minus 110 minus 120. I don't know
what Alex Pierre feels like when he's at
his weight and he's got uh strong yeah I
don't know what I he might be made of
iron like it's he those guys feel
differently you would know better than
anybody some guys just feel differently
like you got a guy like yeah I'm being
polish though you know struggles [__]
polish friends he's also 240 in the off
season he's also he's a very big man but
he's also 40 years old how old is he is
he he's 40. yeah that's he's 40. don't
and you know the timing gets a little
slow when you're 40. time again trust me
my double leg ain't the same when it was
when I was 25. all the time spares no
one and if you're off a second and Alex
can land that uppercut with that power
yeah I'm taking Alex you [__] piece
of what yeah you piece of [__] you are
yeah man I like how your dog is out you
dumb meat pie how are you taking uh you
know why because I want to win oh so you
have an emotional thing in this no I've
never met the guy yeah well Jan is going
to be a tough thing for Alex now I hate
the matchup yeah you're a piece of [__]
our boy wonder boy who was supposed to
come to my show in Greenville left made
me a nice little video saying Brian man
yeah he's a good guy seems like a
sweetheart isn't he he's a nice guy ever
yeah and he says man we got good
comments yeah yeah but but uh Wonder Boy
Mike I was hanging out with the
wonderboy's very good friend who trained
at his school and taught her to school
forever so he came to my show very cool
and uh he was talking about how well
he's a funny guy funny when cameras
aren't on he's a silly goose I don't
know yeah I don't know that okay you
spend time with him though yeah yeah he
trained with us forever so you have
Wonder Boy or Michael Pierre I don't
know Michael Pierre she would if you saw
him Michelle oh Michelle the guy that
does flips
he got exhausted dancing coming to the
stage oh God he's such a character this
guy oh that ponytail awesome
he's awesome he's awesome Mister Steal
Your Girl of course he's mystery I bet
he got a dick on him oh dude that's his
lady
one of melons got all the ladies
wow
dude he's uh
because he'll come forward too and if
you go forward Wonder Boy you're getting
[__] up the Wonder Boy it's a bad
fight if you don't engage with him
because he'll just sit outside and pick
you up pick you apart if you engage
that's when it gets fun yeah like
Woodley didn't engage in we got an awful
fight yeah what do you think then I got
Wonderboy I
but how about Tony Ferguson Bobby green
Tony Ferguson is still fighting
I'm sorry I just he's a big dog in this
it's disrespectful I just don't know why
they give I just think he needs to take
time off his his head I don't know
I I don't understand how many times
would you want to see him get knocked
out honestly how many times
what are we doing I'm Bobby green Notch
how does he get cleared by the
commission
I don't know man I don't run it though I
don't know you'd never get cleared as a
boxer no I'm saying wait when you get
take that kind of damage
I mean they don't give a [__] dude dude
it's meat Bobby Green's so much fun
Bobby Green's so much fun he's talking
to you the whole time he's moving you
know what the the by the at least Bobby
green doesn't sit down on his punches
like Justin gaichi you know
so he's so explosive though Bobby green
yeah I mean knocked out by Drew Dome
it's bad news hey it's so nice we're
doing the shop show they had Derek Lewis
you must have had some different card up
because they had Derek Lewis is the main
card they probably just removed it then
our boy our boy what do you think of
Michael Chase and Kevin Holland you know
who's going to win that right I'm a big
kyosa fan he's on my face and I thought
he's gonna be world champion
welterweight he's following some tough
times yeah Kevin Holland's a
[__] well so Michael had some uh
injuries too he had some issues no but
he went on a run when he got to welcome
wait and then then he got to the top
guys Vicente Luke with a DARS which
pissed me off and then uh because how
you gonna submit GSA that's his thing
it's submitted with the DARS
he was a high school wrestler he wasn't
he didn't even wrestle in college
but uh just got better he's a late
bloomer by the way Michael Jackson is he
fighting at 70 yes because the fact that
he fought at 55 is so obscene he was 205
when it came to my show how much do you
weigh six one six I was like how are you
this big
[__] sucking weight like crazy
oh he [__] up on the shop show team
because you know brought up you had
Derek Lewis so it probably just changed
recently I doubt it because that was the
same because I looked at the sworn I was
doing my notes but that's like whatever
you brought up it had Derek Lewis
fighting on the prelims
yeah man he's falling in tough times
who's Marcos Rosario De Lima used to be
a 205er bring him up he looks like a
Monster uh Derrick Lewis should win that
fight but remember this is in Salt Lake
City so the altitudes would be an issue
for these big boys oh boy that's a
that's a problem
I I think the UFC did it for a reason
because they're like hey uh Derek Lewis
no no [__] fun around you have one
round you know a few on the second or
third you're [__] we're forced you to
engage so you gotta you gotta you gotta
I'll take that fight's not going that
first round I'll take Derek you're gonna
stand him back that's how it was earlier
Wikipedia yeah see that's wrong but I
mean the website just changed
we should be using ufc.com not Wikipedia
well we've been using Wikipedia it's
pretty good well
that's my picks
good card though
but do you have Kevin Holland over our
chances oh I do this to me I like like
Michael Kias is one of my favorite yeah
one of my faves yeah
but
um
business bro I'm not talking about
friendship I'm talking about business
Okay Kevin Horn's a black belt on the
ground too
yeah
when Kevin punches you it's it's really
a problem you lost the Sean Brady which
is nothing you know nothing Sean Brady's
a [__] Savage yeah lots of Vicente
Luke yeah
you want to run there at welterweight
Carlos conda Diego Sanchez ultimate
tooth dos Angels Neil magni that's a
good win you know Magnum is a legit win
yep he's had a great career he's had a
great career I'm leaning towards uh
Kevin Hall
just because there's less mileage on
them because he's black
no I'm just kidding I don't know I I
don't know I can't tell you it doesn't
make sense because I like Kevin but uh
I've always been a fan of Michael he's
great Kevin's been more more active
it's been a while since Michael fought
when was the last time Michael kiss [__]
so Kevin did April of this year
you gotta win which he needed
cases 2021 so there you go it's been a
hot second it's been a hot second now
I'm leaning towards Kevin even more you
have to it's not nothing personal
because I love Michael kiosm but yeah
it's a tough one but but Kevin's just so
active and remember he also uh choked
out Dear ushman yeah he's no joke you
almost forgot y'all must have forgot fun
Fight Card though and your Miss
companion because you're piece of [__]
yeah well I gotta do I'm gonna be doing
uh Ontario no I'm gonna be Ontario's
this weekend I got well that's it this
this weekend dude oh that's this weekend
yeah I'm in Ontario [__] that's right
you're doing companion
for that one have to bro and then next
week you're companion with Rogan and
I'll be I'll be at cap cities in next uh
I'll be at cap cities in Austin little
bird might be there too I know I want to
try to sneak uh when is the companion
though you know during flight times
I know during five hours bro prelims
earlier ah nah you missed it damn it
but I'll I'll I'll be there with you at
Cap City though how
not during the fight night or by getting
it on Friday I'll be there Friday for
you perfect you know I got your back
Daddy I like it I'll be there Friday
Friday everybody oh you know what we
should have started with we got an
announcement oh deal and I are doing
another kid getting back together again
co-headlining at Covina Factory
September 89th September 89 kofino laugh
factories get your tickets I'll even
think it's on any websites yet I can't
wait look at that
yes
dude we were young men back then
young man you know that was taken Graham
Thief Hall gramsey theater in New York
that was great dude yeah that was fun
time damn we've had a 10-year run bro
fight around the cows yeah
I've been together in a hot second hot
second
hopefully we can be fun huh I can't wait
covina's not a bad Drive either good
food around there take your Porsche no
yeah
nah we'll take uh my dad car
it's JB with us too oh good the BMW oh
nice
yeah it's not too it's not too crazy but
it's a drive let's be honest I'll take
my car it takes about an hour yeah
but for a road gig easy man that's easy
great Market too so much better some of
the best pizza
so much better than a plane Ontario I'd
rather fly to New York every day
every year Ontario in Rush Hour the
third day Friday hey kill me yeah it's
gonna be a drive you're going exactly 15
miles an hour three hours above mineral
Ontario
it feels like you're driving through
Iraq too it's not like pretty California
separate when you get out you're like
I'm saying that Airbnb last time
really yeah you're two and a half hours
three hours there at least I don't have
to do during the day that's the problem
it bums you out yeah not a lot I love
the people though I love the animals
great yeah great yeah great crowds
everything is just what are you gonna do
during the day it's just good people if
you leave early enough you'll be a fine
I love performing at Ontario Improv I
actually love it come get something all
right what do you got chin uh real quick
just an update on that Carly girl
that girl that went missing she went
missing for a couple days saw a little
baby on the road basis
real quick Carly
are going crazy and crazier so anyways
cops found out that she was Googling on
the phone uh the movie Taken and how to
get a cash register open it up without
being you know getting caught and taking
the money
um
she's a dumbass she Googled Amber Alert
it doesn't cost money to do an Amber
Alert
oh she was like trying to do an amber
alert a fake one probably on herself a
one-way ticket to Birmingham to
Nashville
uh all these different things she's
screwed like she didn't realize we
called [__] early on she didn't
realize that this he had caught doing
this it's really easy to trace this like
yeah
so what was the point of it they still
she's still not giving she's still not
GoFundMe maybe she's not she's not being
like open and honest about what happened
yet she said she said she was actually
kidnapped and the story was crazy too
like some guy with orange hair and a
bald spot grabbed her when she tried to
get the kid put her in an 18-wheeler
then she tried to escape they put her in
a car all this crap which is you know
come on apparently her boyfriend took
down a social media and like was like
he's like please stop I want no part of
this stop cyber bullying her but it's
like you do stuff like this I mean come
on yeah
wow but she's still not admitting
anything do you see that that uh was it
gig glow is that what they call it
Gigolo Gigolo Gilgo Gilgo uh serial
killer we got more stuff now he had a
secret uh soundproof room underneath his
backyard and there they found for sure
he killed at least one girl there they
don't know if he killed all four there
but one for sure
wow
ugh soundproof basement
vault in his family home
find soundproof basement I think the
wife is the next one get arrested
there's no way she was in on this I've
seen it too many times oh my God
bad guy huh well that's a dungeon that's
so terrifying he was torturing them
horrific that's what he's doing
um I won't play this video the BDK
killer came out was like that guy's
crazy reminds me of myself like that is
not a good endorsement you're not
helping they're both crazy
but they were both they have similar
backgrounds because they're both family
men living in the neighborhood they
blend in you can't tell
so that's always some of the BT BT
calculator is like the head of his
church it was like killing [__] on
the side
yeah crazy dude I'm gonna bear hug the
[__] out of you when I see you again The
Rock
he he looks like he's been through it
man so yes he finally made this Jamie
Foxx finally you know addressing what
happened but he doesn't say what
happened he's just saying like something
got so bad to her I think he can't
that's I'm still I'm still like tripping
out about that from oh my God it has
kicked off YouTube okay yeah all right
you know hey
bye
you know what's wrong look I
man he he got his head tattooed though
I think he does use some stuff
yeah I don't think it's tattoo but I
think I've seen way too much first 48.
okay salt dude that's a [__] therapy
looks he looks like he's been he looks
like he's wearing a Pittsburgh Steeler
helmet a lot of women what do you got 10
what let me see the video I didn't see
this oh it's pretty wild everybody is
praying man sent me messages it's really
long though I cannot even begin to tell
you
um
how far it took me and how how it
brought me back
um you still don't look 100 does he he
speaks well though hell yeah
uh and I know a lot of people were
waiting you know or wanting to hear
updates but to be honest with you
I just didn't want you to see me like
that man you know I want you to see me
laugh and having a good time partying I
get it crying Joe doing the movie
television show I didn't want you to see
me with a
with tubes
um
running out of me and
and trying to figure out uh
if if I was gonna
make it through and I'll be honest with
you my uh my sister's addiction my dog
friend Marie setting my life so
uh to them to God
to a lot of great medical people uh I'm
able to leave you this
uh video it'll humble you I can't tell
you how great it feels hell yeah
but he said he's doing well now and he's
back to doing movies he's one of my
favorites man he's like the most
Hands-On most times person on Earth
right now
plays piano yeah
he's amazing yeah I wonder what exactly
I'm so glad he's okay I was like
do you guys want to talk about the Jason
Aldean hell yeah it's hilarious what is
that what like when is CMT and the
country music and just big big industry
in general can realize they don't have
any power and like they drive what is
this now so Jason Aldean did a music
video and a song called small town yeah
what's going on in the world
well Jason Aldean he comes out with this
song like you know the the trial in a
small town basically saying like all
this crazy [__] going on like if you try
it in a small town like good luck like
we don't play that [__] here all this
woke stuff and rioting like where we're
from we protect our [__] man so don't
try it here and they cancel them like
CMT polls CMT pulls his videos same CMT
same people that pulled when uh Morgan
uh Waylon or Wallen said that n-word
when he's drunk and someone recording
without his consent
Morgan Wallen number one touring artist
now in country by far right underneath
Taylor Swift selling out Jason Aldean
now it's the number one song he's
selling more tickets than ever and now
also other country music artists have
pulled their videos off CMT to you know
like this isn't right man and but then
but then mainstream wants to cancel but
you're fine with [__] you're fine with
the song wet ass [__] on the radio
you're fine with this gangster rap all
that's fine killing each other shooting
each other king Von [__] all that little
Uzi vert and all that [__] all that's
are good to post and do that but then
Jason Aldean goes can't loot my small
town you're not gonna get away with it
we're gonna protect our [__] we protect
cops we like cops and then this gets
pulled down it's insane dude and so
everybody was like no so CMT that's a
good way for CMT to turn into Buzz Light
you Bud Light that's what that's what
because for me I'll never watch CMT now
is that for real it's like I think every
every country music star who believes in
America should pull their their video
down it's like you but you know you you
know what's weird be like this is what
I'm conflicted about because I don't
like cancel culture right I think people
make mistakes and they have a right to
work again I hate to cancel culture
isn't this a form of canceled culture
like what we're doing no I'll tell you
what like Bud Light made a mistake
there's a big difference explain it I'm
just boycotting so what I'm doing with
Bud Light is very simple so you can
still make beer and sell your beer I'm
just not even drinking it I'm just but
I'm I'm a boycott's very different than
cancer we're not canceling we're not
we're not saying we're not blowing up
the manufacturer yes what what what
happens is cancel culture is there's no
there's no evidence there's just there's
allegations or there's you did something
and then they say you can't work well
they take you off they de-platform you
yeah there's a difference between being
de-platformed so you literally they make
you disappear you can't earn a living or
they suppression
yeah but what they do what what this is
It's called a boycott I as a consumer
say I'm just not going to buy your beer
we don't like your message anymore I'm
talking about your beer and that's
that's just all that is expressing my
right to free speech
cancel culture is very different when
your agent drops you when every
corporate sponsor drops you because
they're afraid that they're gonna get
they're going to get accused for
sticking by you yeah just just because
they're close associated with you so
that's a very different thing than than
actually saying you um you stepped
outside of the bounds of what you
provide which is a service I don't agree
with what you did I don't think that
this gender ideology for example is is
healthy safe or true
and so therefore if you're gonna if
you're we're not saying Bud Light can't
sell anymore we're saying we're just not
no I'm not going to do anything but if
you want to do it I'm just going to take
my business elsewhere yeah and there's
nothing wrong with that because you're
still now with CMT the fact that they
did this to this guy God read your
Market CMT yeah know your audience and
you also were unfair you treated him
unfairly you you said it was a lynching
song which it's not do that and that
song and so let's slap yeah so let's so
so it's all good CMT but but guess what
maybe maybe it's time to not listen to
CMT it's not canceling I'm just gonna
I'm just not I don't agree with you I
think you treated somebody unfairly I
don't think you stand for that I
remember CMT not it's just it's just not
the network but CMT control Country
Music Awards it's CMT country music they
control all the awards so Morgan Wallen
wasn't up for any awards that year they
wouldn't let you vote for him even
though he probably would have won yeah
so I think that's how they I think it's
up to uh the consumer and the people
that actually pay cmt's bills and makes
me EMT what they are it's time for them
to step up and say no this won't stand
so let me get they can make the biggest
difference because Luke Bryan pulled his
music videos from CMT shot to Luke Bryan
oh and if a bunch of other ones do it
that's gonna make difference because the
country music like the top dogs are all
a close-knit group yeah so if they all
pull it you know yeah I would remind
people the days the daisy Chicks The
Dixie Chicks they they they're all the
days ago yeah their career was destroyed
because they went bad on well I don't
agree with that but that was the but
hold on it's that that was the them
decided to make a choice to be anti you
know President Bush and then the nation
didn't cancel this one we're not going
to listen to your music anymore but they
were still allowed to make music
the Luke Bryan thing was made from a
satirical thing so he didn't pull it
yeah but of course they still back their
boys but he may not even be able to pull
his videos
the controversial thing I'd listen to
the song I Saw the videos everything
it's yeah there's nothing wrong with it
it's the only controversial thing I
think was they filmed it at that
Courthouse where there was a lynching in
1927. that's the problem that's only
that's something and there's probably
some Native Americans that died on the
ground were doing this show from it's
like you can find that stuff anywhere
I'm sure they tried to find something
and yeah of course but that's the only
thing I could think of
um I don't think it'd be a big deal if
that song didn't slap so by the way is
that song crushing it now it came out in
May but now it's killing it because I
thought it was new I just heard it I was
like oh [__] go Jason Aldean wow number
one
and I'm sure he's gonna sell all the
tickets
oh in the ring oh you don't you think
the country music fan base doesn't
side with CMT dude all these all if I'm
Jason Aldi I'm like hell yeah yeah hell
yeah
that'd be dope
you almost want this like Morgan wants
bigger than ever yeah the left is just
unbelievable man with this stuff you
know Taylor Swift sells so many tickets
she sold the most tickets of all time
she sells so many tickets she's the
number one reason why Hotel have gone
through the roof now like booking a
hotel business was down because she
comes into town the hotels go through
the roof she's that powerful
I think she's beautiful
so this happened uh this morning in
Pasadena during a soccer game oh I saw
this it's in Pasadena this dude
15-year career look
he's trying to keep with it their lap
boom
recently they have no update they drank
two Bud Lights all right he just had
something happen if he uh they said that
he was okay though but it's still too
early to know what's happened well I
just fainted low blood sugar or
something I've seen that happen on TV a
lot now I mean not a lot but a few times
with reporters at his level you're
talking about the high level athletes oh
he's hot oh yeah 15 years is a pro like
Pro what soccer like like elite elite
player yeah
and this one too George oh boy yeah our
good friend
uh he got offered 1.1 billion what one
year to play soccer in the Saudi Arabian
Club I can't pronounce that well from
1.1 and he turned it down right you
gotta go no he turned it down he turned
down their offer we should be thankful
sorry I just don't like basketball
but but but but think about it come on
hand don't look back Reggie Bush said
boy if you don't do go do that one
one point this is all the Saudis have
all the money it's like it's like
Francine got in Tyson Fury
you know how much money Frank's gonna
make when the Saudis go we want it over
here they go dude we got the rights over
here though how much
you know they're doing this with golf
trying to live well no they've done it
dude yeah but they live in PGA or
emerged oh yeah they're together now
they are yeah hold on let me hold on
yeah I know well that happened four
months ago yeah yeah sorry [__] was the
ghost calling
uh I don't see the turn down part he
turned it down okay he did yeah
oh did you see Messi speaking of soccer
that we don't know [__] about did you
see Messi in Miami
Tiger has the new messy outfit he's
calling it more easy right
hold on just I don't have to talk about
last Friday yeah he played his first
game I know he was all over TV and
scored the game-winning goal in overtime
he did he didn't play the whole game to
the very end then he comes in and he
goes oh cool you guys like play soccer
in America very cool put me in coach
Boom game winner runs off the field
gives the Jersey Kim Kardashian says
show them your tits
he didn't say that but in my head oh
look at this this was like one one
he's barely played first game game over
you couldn't write this in a movie dude
oh come on
his teammates like you're so good dude
this is in Miami so good in Miami oh
dude God damn it I wish I was a pro
be a better player and we didn't see any
of that how much fun would that be
to be one of the greatest soccer ball
okay okay hold on I'd rather be Jason
Aldean
hold on
Sports wise you can be oh Jason the
greatest
soccer player wait tennis soccer ball
player baseball player hockey in America
the world well the world you want to do
Premier League soccer yeah everyone
knows about just in the world in America
America basketball yeah like we like
Messi you know it's kind of a big deal
here but in general I really do it [__]
but worldwide
soccer
team than all of them try that my small
town [__]
yeah dude well guys we did it again we
did it again I hope that itching that's
right so briancount.com trying to get my
website back up dude I don't get it dude
whose website's down in 2023. I don't
know I don't know what's happening well
on what your tickets are available on
fatkz.com does it go back to this site
though or no or is it there go go to
Brian's on there and then we'll have
tickets up later today for me and Brian
and years are back together yeah it's
available on uh fatkz.com so get tickets
for Brian for Ontario Austin to Antonio
Austin I will be with Brian so for
Saturday right because I'm gonna pan
your [__] now yep yep but me and Brian
uh September 8th and 9th Covina Laugh
Factory me and the boy are back yeah
Friday Saturday me too dude I'm gonna
slap your [__] face I can't wait hell
yeah uh you might yeah we could try uh
this Friday Pasadena Ice House one show
only I got Jay Moore I got will Burkhart
I got Trey Stewart yeah it's gonna be a
fun one chop and friends is going down
this Saturday tickets almost sold out
one show only at 8pm then Phoenix
Arizona two shows one night Friday night
August 11th hopefully it's not burning
hot
um that's at stand up live in Phoenix
Arizona August 11th I will be at JT's
Wings when I'm not on stage just
gobbling those wings and then Omaha
Nebraska is August 16th one night only
Kansas City Missouri one night only on
August 17th then I go to Ohio to end
August August 30th and 31st I'm in
Liberty Township Ohio and Columbus Ohio
yeah there you go and then uh September
we got spoken in Washington I'm all over
baby but uh yeah ice house this Friday
and then August 11th Phoenix next week
I'm in Austin with Brian count I'll do a
little pop-up uh at capcities
briancount.com is working now go to it
I'm refreshing
yeah that's not working man
that's all right all right kids love you
we're out